after a long rain delay tonight
ian anderson sent for his sixth major
league start tonight he'll face the
marlins for the second time in his
brief big league career so corey
dickerson at long last is going to step
into the batters box
and there's the change up dickerson
didn't get it and anderson off to a good
start his 36th strikeout
in 27 innings pitched it is really
pouring yeah
fly ball to straight away center acuna
having all kinds of trouble with the
lights in the rain and he has to make
the catch almost sitting down
in the center field grass
that's not a good sign when you're out
there trying to do that in the first
wow pablo lopez this is his 11th start
of the season coming off his fifth win
of the year and akuna junior is on to
start the braves half of the first
inning here's the pitch
and freeman pops it up into shallow left
and this is rojas under the ball
and makes the catch mizuna is putting up
a good year
and a called strike three inside corner
perfect pitch for pablo
darno in there behind the plate tonight
the pitch here and it swung on and
missed and this time around
pablo wins that battle with darno he
struck him out
trying to get sharp now but it's raining
what's important
keep that ball dry big fella so it
doesn't slip out of your hands
now man joyce is up and a swing and a
miss second strikeout for
anderson joyce expanded his strike zone
and walks away mumbling
and chad wallach is on and it didn't get
that one that was up and
out of the zone ian anderson has his
third strikeout braves go back to work
scoreless game
pablo lopez back to work here in the
third following two strikes on
echeverria
and a called strike three pablo has
looked
sharp tonight that's three strikeouts as
he faces acune junior for a second time
tonight 3-2 pitch to acuna
is swung out and missed he pumped a
fastball by him at 94 miles per hour so
back-to-back case to begin the third
inning for lopez that's four in the game
so two on and two out and that'll bring
up darno well they can get out of it
just as quick
one good pitch and maybe that's it to
get him out of it
back into shallow right drifting birdie
birdie will make the catch after a
couple of errors tonight miami has three
hits
but nobody's broken through yet in a
scoreless game two on for rojas who
popped out to the catcher his first time
up
first pitch swing popped up that is
headed down the left-field line ball's
going to be pushed back by the wind
and echeveria and foul ground is going
to make the play and rojas is beside
himself he's popped up twice
and it's all for two two out so break
there for ian anderson wallach struck
out on a pitch collarbone high his first
time up
as this one's lifted into left field
push that one back thank you very much
wallach is over two scoreless game
bottom of the fourth two and two to
swanson
he struck him out pretty good changeup
from lopez
pitching to both sides of the play it
can't just be the fastball good circle
change
now marcakis 02. marcakis pops this one
up
wallock is going to be the one to make
the catch
and pablo's through four and the marlins
have runners on the corners
a golden opportunity here in the sixth
matt joyce to the plate
the one-two he got him joyce chased one
up and out of the strike zone
second time joyce has been retired on
strikes now the double play is in order
and a frustrated rojas is the hitter
and strike three right down broadway he
couldn't pull the trigger back to back
strikeouts after miami had him first and
third
they need a two out hit here wallach is
ahead in the count two and oh
there it is wallach with a base hit into
right field that'll get the marlins on
the board cooper's on his way to third
and chad wallach comes through with a
two-out single
[Applause]
the celebration in the marlins dugout
all the marlins are on their feet they
have finally broken through
an rbi single for chad wallach and the
marlins looking for more
john birdie with a couple of hits
tonight rips one fair down the left
field line and toward the corner
cooper will score wallach is heading
toward third
trey's waving him around here comes the
throw
albies double clutches and chad wallach
is in there safe
the marlins have a three nothing lead
and
he gets a bunch of bad luck in the sixth
inning for ian anderson he leaves
trailing three nothing
went on the seventh of the dh aguilar
who's got hit in three abs
minter home with a 1-2 and angular
hits this one to left center field it is
out of there a home run for jesus
aguilar
and the marlins extend their lead it's
now four nothing
and adam duvall bats with the bases
loaded nobody out
a big mess for brandon kinsler trying to
clean it up for brad boxberger who
did not retire batter and he struck him
out
a big out number one a grin from kinsler
i got him the batter
sharply hit and throw off the glove of
ro house that's going to score a couple
of runs
dansby swanson makes it a four to two
game
first pitch rifled it to the left side
and rojas couldn't flag it down
and it's a dani echeveria who sends home
an 0-1 pitch
that's in the air out towards center
coming in
is martay he'll close on it and make the
catch
well here it is bottom of the ninth
marlins with a four to two lead two
balls two strikes two outs
and a cold strike three
it's a marlins win 4-2 the final score
the marlins
inch closer